welcome everybody today we're going to
be sort of uh resetting taking an
overview of the political climate in the
united states as we're now just what is
it it's about eight uh eight nine weeks
from the 2022 midterm elections and one
of the big
stories one of the big contexts in which
we now have to think about these
midterms and what are the next two years
of american politics sort of going to be
like is the now extraordinarily notable
spike in president joe biden's approval
rating now we have to also understand
context and the context is this
extremely partisan status quo of the
united states where
your range of approval probably is only
between you know 35 and 65 or something
like that and what i mean by that is
when you
divide up the electorate
into people who just don't pay attention
uh and then those who will always
approve of a democratic president and
disapprove of a republican one and then
those who will always disapprove of a
democratic president and approve of a
republican one and then you say okay
who's actually willing to be swayed and
to sometimes say they approve and
sometimes say they don't not based
simply on the party of the president
you probably only have a functional
approval range of somewhere between 35
and 65 and maybe it's a little wider
than that we used to say it's between 20
and 80. i don't know what it is
right now we are continuing to see joe
biden's approval climb and climb and
climb
now up to 42.4
in an average of approval polls now this
bottomed out
um in mid-may at i'm sorry in uh no not
in mid-may in in the middle of july
at 37.5
so very roughly speaking to go from 37.5
to 42-4
you're talking about a 12 or 13ish
percent increase not percentage points
everybody relax
percent 12 to 13 percent increase
roughly you can check my math on that
remember the storyline that at this
point we used to say
at this point in joe biden's presidency
he is less popular than every president
dating all the way back to truman and i
believe it was 46. we used to say that
we have a very different situation now
not only has joe biden's approval rating
gone up at a dramatic rate
but joe biden now and i'll pull these
numbers up for you joe biden now has
pulled even with donald trump in terms
of approval at this point in their
respective presidencies
joe biden has pulled roughly even with
bill clinton at this point in their
respective presidencies even if you look
at reagan
biden is now basically where reagan was
at this point in his presidency and same
thing if you look at jimmy carter as
well and only a couple of points
interestingly enough only a couple of
points below
uh barack obama at this point in time
so what is the meaning of all this what
is the importance of all this well
if people don't show up to vote in the
midterms the importance is essentially
nothing the whole context here is
historically when a president takes the
white house when for example a democrat
takes the white house from a republican
in the first midterm election which
comes two years later democrats usually
don't do well this might mean if they
have the house and senate they lose both
or it might mean if they if they don't
have them they fall behind by an even
greater margin we saw this in
1994 with bill clinton as an example it
almost always happens
however and we'll look at where the
numbers are maybe wednesday thursday
as of right now democrats are favored to
maintain control of the senate
potentially even expanding it beyond the
50 50-50 majority they have now with
kamala harris's tie-breaking vote and
although the house is still
statistically
very likely it's it's almost four to one
likely to go to uh republicans
there are now paths to democrats keeping
control of the house now i'm not first
of all i'm not making any predictions
but i'm not i'm not predicting that
democrats are going to keep the house
but there is now a story to be told
there is now a path
in which you could make that case but it
all depends on turnout the 2018 midterm
turnout was 53
and that was the highest midterm turnout
in four decades what i mean by that is
midterm turnout is normally very very
low you don't normally get even 53
turnout i think the last presidential we
had roughly 60 turnout so
it is
i know it's cliche at this point to say
it but it will come down to who actually
gets voters out and it is an opportunity
with joe biden's spiking approval the
humiliation that is taking place for
trump and the maga movement
it's an opportunity
for democrats to do something that would
not be historically indicated
based on what we have seen in midterms
in the past we'll update the numbers on
house and senate wednesday thursday by
the end of the week
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the u.s alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 percent made from bamboo a
bamboo stock keeps growing it can be
harvested forever it means that the soil
and the ecosystem aren't disrupted no
carbon removing trees are cut down the
paper industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one american uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required
put an end to that right now with real
paper the best part is this stuff is
really great it's just normal soft
toilet paper real paper loves the david
pakman show they're giving my audience
thirty percent off your first order and
free shipping when you go to real paper
dot com slash pacman and use the code
pacman at checkout the link is down
below